fuyez je vous propose de terminer cette
édition d'ailleurs en retrouvant jean
paul sartre en retrouvant un extrait des
mains sales
vous ne jouiez pas dans cette pièce mais
vous en aviez fait la mise en scène
c'était il ya déjà pas mal d'années
sur scène on retrouve paul guers
dominique morin amélie prévost et annick
bertin à l'extrait donc des mains sales
mis en scène par daniel jeulin chatel
chatel et chatel lui un extrait de cette
pièce dont je pense beaucoup d'amateurs
de théâtre se souviennent encore je vous
avais bien dit que nous pourrions pas
nous entendre avec ces gens là nous
avons les deux tiers du pays
l'argent les armes des formations
paramilitaires entraîné sans compter la
priorité morale que nous donne nos
martyrs et voilà une poignée d'hommes
ceux qui réclament tranquillement la
majorité au comité central
alors c'est non c'est non nous passons
de vous alors allez vous en car ce qui
regardaient le prince
il est plus malin goût il a déjà compris
nous ne pouvons pas rejeté ses
propositions sans examen karski ce ne
sont pas des propositions
ce sont des exigences absurde que je
refuse de discuter en 42 la police
traque et vous aimez les nôtres vous
organiser des attentats contre le régent
nous sabotions la production des
logements locatifs du pentagone
rencontre un petit gars de chez nous il
y en avait toujours un des deux qui
restent sur le carreau qu'aujourd'hui
brusquement qu'on voulait tout le monde
s'embrasse
pourquoi pour le bien de la patrie
pourquoi n'est ce pas le même bien qu'en
est ce que ça ne serait pas parce que
les russes ont battu par lu ça
stalingrad effet toutes allemandes sont
en train de perdre la guerre
il est évident que l'évolution du
conflit créé une situation nouvelle mais
c'est ici que vous voyez très bien au
contraire vous voulez sauver les
dirigeants si convaincu mais vous voulez
la sauvette est recalé avec son régime
d'inégalités sociales et ses privilèges
de classe quand les allemands semblaient
vaquin votre père c'est ranger de leur
côté
aujourd'hui tu as ans tournait cherche à
s'accommoder des russes